suisse alors oui en nerveuse est sujette
à la fantaisie un parfait exemple
d'hystérie elle sera sur pied en un rien
de temps
on a laissé passer sa peine
ouais
non
je vais très bien
des absentes et trop longtemps à nice
il ne faut pas négliger cmdp histoire
qu'est ce qui ne va pas le chapelier
il s'appelait lier mon meilleur ami je
suis prête à tout pour l'idée ce sera
une course contre le temps
il vaut mieux ne pas l'avoir pour et
demi le son est une personne
mes amis votre temps s'est écoulé il
nous a bloqués à une minute de l'heure
du thé leur but et les bons jours à
l'iss
le chapelier compte sur toi
oh non nous comptons tous sur toi
kouassi
abonnés alice de plus agaçantes plus
égoïste que tu ne l'a jamais été
je pensais pas bronché
ou au nom sort comme aux jo
oh
désolé